Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and we're still talking about certainty versus doubt.
And in this final story, the two once again collide,
but this time it's in a way that's almost unimaginable.
I remember running along a railroad track,
a seldom used railroad track, but just thinking, God,
it would be a blessing if a train just came along in front of me. It was like
we need to warn you now if there are younger sensitive listeners listening right
now, this next piece depicts graphic violence and it can be pretty disturbing.
So if you're listening with kids, uh,
this would be a good time to ask them to leave the room or a to for you to put
on headphones. This piece comes from our producer Pat Walters.
I guess we could just start at the beginning. So could you just, I don't know,
set the scene. It was 1985. Yes, it was 1985.
Um, so this is penny penny Burnson and in 1985 penny and her husband Tom,
I'm here with living in Wisconsin on the shores of Lake Michigan in a little
town called Manitowoc.
On a small third generation family business and what kind of business was that?
Bernstein's candies are open seven days a week,
10 to ten three hundred sixty three days a year.
But sometimes in the summer opinion time would cut out early and go to the
beach. That's where we went that day. July 29th,
1985 blue skies probably in the seventies perfect day to be at the beach with
your family.
They parked the car two three o'clock in the afternoon and set up camp near the
water and I was reading a book about Lizzie Borden, the infamous x murderer,
but after about like an hour of reading this book,
Penny set it down and said to my husband,
I can't believe I'm reading this gruesome book. On a beautiful day,
I'm going to go for a jog, penny peds north along the water.
And when I was within about half a mile of my starting point,
there was a guy standing with a leather jacket slung over his shoulder and as I
jog by, he said, it's a great day. I glanced at him and said,
it's a beautiful day for a jog. It didn't really think anything of it.
Jog three miles turned around and I saw the same guy come out from under a half
fallen tree and head towards me.
She started to run and we should say it.
This next part gets graphic and violent.
Made the mistake of running into the water to try and get away from him and
realized how slowly I was running in the water.
As I got ran back to the beach, this man caught up with me,
put me in a choke hold and said,
we're going to take a little walk up into the sand dunes.
He pushed me up over this first sand dune where we're no longer visible to
anybody. Started asking me to do sexual things.
He was trying to remove my swimsuit and I twisted to try and get away and he
tightened his script and said, do what I tell you. I've got a knife.
Two thoughts went through my mind.
Stay really calm and get a good look at this guy.
Caucasian, Sandy, blonde hair, curly beard and mustache. Erie hands, Short,
stubby fingers. He pushed me down on the ground and was kneeling over me and uh,
when I was refusing he would,
what he would do was he would strangle me until I would about lose consciousness
and he would loosen his grip and say, now, are you going to do it?
And I would refuse. And as I'm talking,
I managed to get one leg up and I kicked him in the groin.
But unfortunately it didn't incapacitate him. It enraged him and he said, no,
I'm going to kill you now. You're going to die.
Meanwhile,
Tom is getting worried because she was so predictable in her patterns.
She would normally be gone 45 minutes to an hour. After an hour and a half,
you started pacing the beach at two hours. He called the cops.
The police brought in jet-skis were like, were you,
were you thinking that she'd,
I thought I was fairly convinced that she probably had drowned in Manitowoc.
You don't think about crime. You didn't lock your doors. You didn't, you know,
many people left their keys in their car.
He started, I'm hitting my head on either on a rock or a tree stump,
some hard object.
At one point he broke my nose and then strangled me till I lost consciousness.
Sometime later, penny woke up when I came to, um,
I was lying on my back in the sand. She's sad that she was naked and alone.
I thought maybe he's in the woods, you know, watching to see if,
if I've survived or if he's accomplished what he set out to do.
So I tried to stand up, was too weak and fell over.
And she noticed when she fell down that her hands were covered in blood.
And I thought, yeah,
mm,
this is evidence. I need to preserve this. So I crawled through the sand,
kind of on my knees, on the heels of my hands,
making sure she was keeping her fingers up out of the sand.
As soon as I saw her, I knew that she had had been beaten.
You never want to see someone like that. And you know,
I hope I never see that again.
The paramedics, the rest opinion of the Er. Next thing she remembers,
she was lying in a hospital bed surrounded by doctors and nurses stitching
facial cuts, and then there's a female deputy who is questioning me.
She has opinion to describe the guy, Caucasian sandy blonde hair,
early [inaudible] stubby fingers.
The next morning the cops brought Penney down to the police station for a lineup
and this is where you like go into a room and there's a one way mirror.
You can see them. They can't see you. There were nine guys,
each of the nine had a number around their neck from one to nine she looked at
one guy than another than another,
and when I came to, I don't know if he was number three,
I don't recall exactly one particular guy of the nine.
The hair on the back of my neck stood up.
I remember the color draining from my face. Visceral gut reaction like,
oh my God, this was the guy. Barely any time had passed into the attack.
She was positive.
The sheriff wasn't surprised. They'd had their eye on this guy for a while.
His name was Steven Avery. He'd been arrested for some small time stuff,
Berkeley cruelty to animals and most recently attempted assault rifle point.
He'd pulled a gun on a woman, so to the DA and dated him for attacking penny.
The trial was fast, very fast.
Penny got on the stand and said bye for some certain that Steven Avery was the
man who assaulted me. She, she,
she had no doubt she looked people squarely in the eye.
Her recollections were unequivocal. She was a very strong witness.
This is Fred Hazelwood. He was the judge on the case. You're on mandatory. Cody.
Tell me what, tell me about his alibi.
His alibi was that he just didn't have the time to commit the crime cause he was
shopping. He bought some paint, I believe, or drywall compound.
I'm not sure what he was also working that day before the alleged assault,
helping his family poured cement for some project at hole.
That was his testimony and the testimony of a whole bunch of other witnesses.
16 only problem was nearly all of them were family and the stories were too
similar. This is Tom, again, virtually identical,
sounded like they had gotten together and talked.
That was a credibility issue that affected the defense witnesses and there was
one other big problem for Avery is close.
There was not a microscopic speck of concrete dust on any of the clothes that he
wore that day.
And he indicated to trial that he had worked the end of the concrete shoot.
Well anyone that has ever done that at the end of a concrete truck knows that
that just comes out and splashes
after deliberating for two days. The jury found Steve Avery guilty,
guilty on three counts as I recall. Yeah. Sexual assault,
15 years attempted murder, 15 years and I believe false imprisonment,
two years for false imprisonment, 32 years altogether to be served consecutively
[inaudible]
so you go back to the chocolate shop and try to carry on with life as it was
before essentially. But that obviously wasn't too easy.
Nightmares, flashbacks. She was angry, you know, blowing up at my kids,
her husband.
Sometimes I wouldn't want my husband to be protective and other times he would
think he was being protective. And I would say like I can take care of myself.
When a guy on the street whistled at her,
I turned around and just let loose with every obscenity in the book. You know,
I just, she started seeing a therapist,
which helped a little but even a year after Steve's conviction she was still
struggling with all this anger.
And then one snowy afternoon,
maybe winter of 86 87 you went to see a talk by the social worker,
Dr Mark on bright from the University of Minnesota.
And I don't remember exactly what he said,
I don't think he used the word forgiveness,
but he said at some point victims reached the point where they understand that
the anger and hatred they're feeling is really damaging themselves in their
families and they need to let go of it.
And I left the presentation at the next break I went home,
I got my country skis,
I went to point beach state park and skied to the point where I was exact spot
where I'd been assaulted and basically said to myself, Steve,
you don't have power over me anymore.
So that was a turning point.
Penny actually started working in the prisons.
She'd go and tell inmates or story
hoping to teach the impact of crime and hope that they might make the leap to
changing their behavior. Meanwhile, Steven Avery, um,
has a number of appeals and he's turned down at all his appeals.
She had told the district attorney, if anyone,
someone just breathed Steven Avery's name in court,
I want to be notified and I want to be there for every hearing.
And I did show up. I,
I'm getting more and more angry every time there is appeal.
Like is there no finalities there no closure to this.
He kept asking the court to review the evidence over and over again
and I'm thinking, why is he so persistent?
Mm.
And then one Sunday morning in early September, in 2003,
18 years after Steve Avery's conviction pending gets a call from her lawyer
friend Janine and Janine has called and said, can I stop by?
I want to talk to you about a restorative justice initiative that Marquette
frankly was the truth, but it wasn't why I was driving a Manitowoc.
On a Sunday on her way.
Janine called Penny's husband who had left town for a business trip that
morning. Janine told me what she had just discovered and heard.
It was about a DNA test, chess time to turn around.
And Tom and I both pulled into the driveway together simultaneously.
I walk outside and both of them are Ashen and in that moment
she knew, I knew instantly.
Well I always remember the look on her face.
The DNA is back. Ken is not Steven Avery.
She just, she just fell apart.
I told her I wanted to go in and sit down and um,
she went and sat on the couch next to time and explained to her the Wisconsin
innocence project had reevaluated some of the biological material from the crime
scene,
some hairs and determine that an innocent person has spent 18 years,
I think it was 18 years,
one month and 13 days in prison for something he did not do.
Yeah, no, she looked very frightened and I said, penny,
I want you to remember all the good you've done working in prisons,
all the men you've reached. You know, if, I mean, she didn't say much.
I remember
for feeling if I wrote down every good deed I had done from the day I was born
until today,
it would not possibly be sufficient to balance the scales in terms of this
horrendous error that I've made.
That day was worse than the day I was assaulted.
And there was one more thing then I learned. Not only was there an exoneration,
but there was a hit.
The court told
penny that the DNA belonged to a man named Gregory Allen,
who at that moment was in prison for a very brutal rape of a woman in Green Bay,
Wisconsin. You'd actually been charged with an attempted assault,
um, the same beach where I was assaulted. His nickname was the Sandman
because he liked to come up or the sand dunes and grab someone.
And for 10 years while Steve Avery was in prison, he'd walked free.
So I'm thinking how many other women have had their lives turned upside down and
inside out because I miss identified the man who assaulted me.
As it turned out, Gregory Allen was serving his sentence,
a 60 year sentence at the prison in Green Bay where penny had actually been
working. And as a matter of fact,
he was about two weeks from being in penny's next class.
No Way. And No, absolutely.
And so penny would never have known this man that would have been sitting feet
away from her in his cell.
They found a scrap book where he had documented all the appeals of Steven Avery
over all those years. Oh, that's really creepy.
That's more than creepy. September 11th, 2003,
Steve Avery was set free.
As soon as he walked out of the gate of the prison, he was mobbed by reporters.
It was the news story in Wisconsin and he was considered a celebrity.
There was a legislator who actually put together, um,
a Steven Avery Fund that people can contribute to because they really had no
resources and no job skills because he's been in prison for 18 years.
Um, you know,
there was a beauty salon in Green Bay that gave him a makeover.
I remember sending my husband out of town and saying, no,
I just need to be alone.
[inaudible]
and I decided I'm going out running,
and I remember running along a railroad track,
a seldom used railroad track, but just thinking, God,
it would be a blessing if a train just came along in front of me. It was like,
what do I do? [inaudible]
I can't make this right. She says,
every time she saw Steven Avery's face,
he was on the front page of the new art local Manafort newspaper.
Every everyday for two to three weeks, two things would happen. She'd think,
how could I have done this to this man? But at the very same moment,
she thought that the hair on the back of my neck would stand up.
You had an after you knew after I knew. I knew intellectually he was innocent,
but emotionally,
this is the man who I've seen in my nightmares and flashbacks for 18 years.
So there's two weeks after where his face is in the paper every day.
It must have been very strange. It was strange. Yeah.
And then it's also strange to feel like an offender. A little aside here.
And when I saw Gregory Allen's picture,
the picture of my actual perpetrator [inaudible],
there was absolutely no physical, um,
reaction from me. I would swear I'd never seen him before in my life.
So my therapist said to me,
you will never be able to attach to Gregory Allen the feelings you had towards
Steven Avery.
What you have to do is work on removing those feelings from Steve [inaudible]
and looking at Steve as this is an innocent person.
Not long after his exoneration penny had written to Steve asking if she could
meet him and apologize in person.
And about a year and a half after his exoneration, he agreed.
I was so nervous. Can you set the scene? Are you in?
We're a little room small office,
like a two room office in a legislative building in the state capitol.
There's a cell phone, a few chairs. Penny got there first.
Eventually Steve Walked in. Steve had, uh,
his attorney Keith Finley there from the innocence project. I stand up,
I extend my hand to Steve. He gives me this hardy handshake.
Our lives have been intertwined for almost two decades,
and it's the first time we've physically touched, touched.
He sits down,
we talked about things like he had a nephew who was killed in a car accident
when he was in prison and couldn't go to the funeral. His grandmother died.
He couldn't go to her funeral. His wife had divorced him.
He's a strange from his children. Um, and some of them I know,
he had one daughter who really stood by him and so I brought up these losses and
apologized for each one individually. He, he's very quiet,
sort of just acknowledge them with a nod of his head and he said,
I don't blame you.
I blame the police because it turned out in the weeks before penny was attacked,
the police had been watching Gregory Allen because he was unknown sex offender.
They were actually tailing him for the two weeks prior to my assault,
checking on him sometimes as often as a dozen times a day on July 29th,
1985 the day I was assaulted. They checked on him once in the morning.
And then due to a high volume of police calls,
we're unable to check on him any more that day and that's the afternoon I was
assaulted eventually after opinions,
Steve had been sitting in that little room for awhile. Time was up and weed,
there was no more to be sad and I stood up and walked over to Steven and said to
Steve, is it okay if I give you a hug? And he didn't even respond.
He just grabbed me in a big hair bear hug and I said,
so only he could hear Steve. I'm so sorry. And he said, it's okay. This was over
[inaudible]
and for him to say, it's okay, it's over.
when I know full well it's his journey's just beginning and he's got a hell of a
road. Yeah.
[inaudible]
that's one of the most grace-filled things that's ever been said to me.
[inaudible] fast forward about two years after that meeting,
I get a call from Janine guest ski, my attorney friend,
the one who delivered the news about the exoneration who says something's
happen.
There's a woman photographer who's missing Teresa Halbach disappeared October
31st after visiting the suspect Steven Avery to take pictures of a car.
He was selling three n they are searching the Avery property.
I encouraged her, I tried to tell her stay out of this,
but anyone in the local news and said, I cannot believe this,
but she didn't believe it could be Steven Avery,
that she didn't believe he would be capable of such a thing.
And other people in town thought that too,
that this was just another false accusation.
But eventually after a couple of days of searching search,
the remains of Teresa's body burn human bone and teeth were for eventually found
in a burn barrel at the Avery auto salvage yard.
Steven every claim that he was innocent that he was set up by the police.
But a few months later his nephew came forward and he tells police in an
interrogation that the day of the murder he went to Steven Avery's trailer here
heard screams inside.
Steven came to the door and a tee shirt in gym shorts who sweating and inside
the nephew sees Teresa Halbach bound to the bed.
And what happens next according to Stephen's nephew,
is one of the most awful things I've ever heard.
Steven asks his nephew to Rape Teresa with him and then together they kill her.
Oh my. Oh my God.
[inaudible]
you start questioning your own judgment.
I can't even trust my senses. I can't trust my eyes to tell me what,
you know what I thought I recorded accurately about the world.
And then when he gets convicted for killing Teresa, it's like,
you know what kind of character judge am I? No, I can't even judge character.
I can't.
She had been certain twice and Rome twice and then a worse thought occurred to
her.
Would Teresa Halbach be alive today if I hadn't missed identified my assailant?
Meaning what exactly? Like, well, I accused Steve of something he doesn't do.
He's convicted. He spends 18 years in prison.
Prison is enormously damaging to guilty people.
What happens to someone who is innocent?
In other words, did her initial certainty that Steve Avery was her assailant,
did that turn him into the guy who murdered Teresa Halbach? No,
I uh, no, no.
Judge Hazelwood doesn't fight that argument. Not at all. Not at all. For one.
If you look at the group of people who can set free after a wrongful conviction,
the vast majority of them do. Okay.
They don't commit serious crimes after they've been released from prison.
And this was a man with a violent past. Oh yeah.
Well before Penny ete pulled the gun on a woman's in the broad light of day and
demanded that she come with them.
Nothing happened because the police intervened. But what if they hadn't?
I saw the potential for violence in him. Uh,
but I would be wrong to say I saw in him a Teresa Halbach.
I didn't until I asked him if this case had shaken his confidence in his
judgment the way it had for penny.
Um, first I tried to figure out what in the world did we do wrong?
And, um, I pretty much came to the conclusion that, uh,
at least as far as the courts are concerned,
we did get it right and we still got a bad result. That's,
that's going to be a problem.
As long as humans judge other human activity,
we're not always going to get it right.
That's actually the one thing we can be certain of it says.
But cases like Avery are, are rare.
I was 25 years on the bench and 15 years or more as a lawyer before that.
And I don't think I've ever seen one quite like Steven Avery.
He says, Steven Avery is an outlier. He's the lesson you don't learn.
Yeah. It's like I was fishing last spring in Sanibel
[inaudible]
on Sanibel island and I was in up to my waist, uh, trying to, uh,
a fly casting for a snuck to kind of fish. And uh,
all of a sudden this rather dark shape,
swam right by me about eight feet long.
I thought to myself, that's a bull shark.
And here I am waist deep and this shark swam maybe a foot away from me as he
went by. What if they bumped into me? Yeah,
what are the odds of this happening? But, uh, you know, life is like that.
We've, we faced the unexpected, the unknown and,
but you're not going to never go fishing there again, are you? Oh No, no,
I wouldn't, that wouldn't keep me from going fishing.
Then again, the judge didn't get bitten.
I kept thinking over and over at the end of this, like the Halbach family.
How did they move on after something like this? Did you call them? I tried.
I reached out to a couple of the family members, but I never heard back.
And what about Benny?
Well, she and Tom sold the chocolate shop and moved to Chicago.
Well, I'm retired. So right now I'm doing a lot of volunteer work, um,
center on wrongful convictions, children's hospital.
I volunteer at the Morton Arboretum.
And so a variety of things and all together. Yeah,
she seems to be doing just fine. I mean, I questioned much more.
I questioned things a lot more. Yeah,
I think there's much more doubt and I think I'm much more comfortable living
with uncertainty. I've kind of had,
I mean I have to be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Pretty sure Pat Walters for more information on anything that you heard in this
hour, visit radiolab.org thanks to pat,
thanks to Lulu and all the producers who helped us with this episode.
And thank you guys for listening.
[inaudible]
so that was the story as we told it back in 2013,
couple of years later, uh,
Netflix released the documentary series called making a murderer.
It's a really deep dive into a part of the story that we only mentioned towards
the end and rather quickly,
which is the conviction of Steven Avery for the murder of Teresa Halbach.
Now we sort of talked about it based on our best understanding of the evidence
at the time. Making a murderer goes really,
really deep 10 hours deep into this question.
And there are some details that they uncover many,
many details that made us think differently about how we understood that aspect
of the story and how we presented it, who spat with more detail.
So let me just walk you through real quick a few of the things that are
important to that part of the story.
Given the way that we told it in our original piece.
First thing is the confession. We say that, you know,
Steven was arrested for this murder and then his nephew came forward and
confessed.
Turns out that that confession is not a very straightforward piece of evidence.
It came from his 16 year old nephew who has a very low IQ and a fourth grade
reading level that the nephew didn't come forward exactly,
but rather the police pulled him out of class,
questioned him many times without an attorney,
asked him hundreds of very leading questions.
And the kicker of that part of it is that this story that he told about all
those awful things that happened in the bedroom,
there's no actual physical evidence to back up any of it.
So that's the confession.
The other thing is the context in which this whole thing is happening.
Steve had filed a huge $36 million civil suit against the county right after
he'd been exonerated. It was going really well.
Some major evidence against the county had come out.
This is what was happening when Theresa hobbits body was found in Steven Avery's
backyard. So when we said Steven every claimed that he was framed by the police,
there's actually a little more teeth to that statement then you might've assumed
when you listen to our story originally
and there's lots, lots more, it's a filmmakers spent 10 years on this.
They find out things that make you question the evidence the police use to
convict Steven Avery.
And it made pat start to wonder if every should've ever been convicted at all.
So he called up the filmmakers. Hello. Hi Pat, this is Moira. Hi Laura.
Hi Pat. Their names are Moira Demos and Laura are a charity. And uh,
he basically asked them,
do you think Steven Avery is innocent?
I mean,
one of the many things I learned through this decade long experience is,
you know, the humility to, to accept that. I don't know. Um,
we don't think the truth emerged. Um, here with respect to the Halbach case,
we don't, we don't know what happened to her.
It doesn't mean that we're convinced of Steven Avery's innocence or if that or
that that was even of concern to us. You know, I, I think of it as, you know,
I don't know whether it's the carrot or the sort of cardboard rabbit that's on
the dog track. That's, you know, it's, it's making the dogs run.
I mean it's the engine that gets this story going,
but it's the story that's the point. Not the,
not the thing that we know that people are interested in clearing Steven Avery
or Brendan Dassey, his name was never our objective. You know,
one of the themes in the series is the danger of a rush to judgment.
And you know, we now see that in 2015 in the responses to the series,
you know, people are being very quick to name suspects,
to spout opinions about who did it. And,
but I w I feel like it just makes me wonder like if like you spend a week
learning about something and then at the end of the week you say, okay,
now I'm going to say something about what I know or you spend a month thinking
about something or three months and at the end of it you have to say something.
Well, I actually think that's one of the points of the series.
I do understand how that's hard to grapple with.
And I think we are trying to challenge the viewer to deal with how hard it is to
embrace ambiguity. Perhaps you can never
reach a place of certainty, but you should put some energy into it.
Um, so if we let go of certainty and, um, you know,
demand a system that gives you a sense of reliability,
at least, you know,
that can be a goal that can maybe alleviate some of those terrible feelings.
[inaudible].
Thanks again to reporter Pat Walters and of course, to the filmmakers,
Laura Ricciardi and Moira Demos.